Salut à tous c’est Pêcheurs De Trésors.
Vous le reconnaissez ?
C'est l’aimant Beast de chez Maison de la détection
et regardez ce qu'ils viennent
de nous envoyer
une attache
pour accrocher deux aimants ensemble.
Vous pouvez attacher tout types
d'aimants là dessus des 360 degrés.
C'est l'idéal, bien sûr.
Aujourd'hui,
on va faire le crash test
Regardez le montage.
En fait, les deux aimants quand ils sont
montés comme ça, ils se repoussent.
C'est pas facile à monter,
il ne faut pas s'écraser les doigts,
mais regardez, ils se repoussent.
Ce qui va permettre normalement
d'avoir deux fois plus d'objets.
Il faut savoir qu'un seul aimant
comme ça, c'est 1400 kilos de puissance.
Les deux cumulés, on arrive à 2800kg.
Et en terme de poids, là
on est sur un montage qui fait plus de 3 kg
On va voir ce qu'on arrive à faire.
On fait un bon petit mouvement
de balancier, Rasta tu es prêt ?
Aimant lancé
J’ai couvert la moitié du canal, c'est pas mal.
Là j'ai l'impression d’avoir
un objet, mais je suis même pas sûr
Si, je dois avoir quelque chose quand même
Une ceinture de voiture
Ouais, une ancienne
OK, bon ce n’est pas vide
On relance tout de suite.
Vérifiez, comme se sont deux aimants neufs.
C'est que ça bouge pas. Que ça bouge pas
sans coincer les doigts.
Entre on ne sait jamais
s'il y a une inversion des pôles
et que que je perdais phalanges.
Sur des pôles.
C'est pour la Terre. C'est
un. Phénomène climatique.
Ça marche pas. Pour le néodyme.
C'est super lourd.
Je vais avoir des bras
mon pote, c'est incroyable
ça va, ça se lance et ça fait un big plouf
Et si vous voulez acheter
ce genre de choses,
elles sont disponibles dès maintenant
sur le site de Maison de la Détection.
Vous avez toujours le code promo
Pêcheur de trésor qui s'affiche ici
et qui offre 5% sur toute la boutique,
y compris sur les détecteurs de métaux.
Si c'est votre truc.
Mais pour les objets
qui viennent pas parfois,
je pense que ça peut faire la différence.
Ça fait la différence.
Parce qu'il
y a vraiment un truc à jouer. Là,
j'ai un truc, j'ai un truc.
Pour l'instant, c'est validé.
Un chacun
ça a l'air cool. C'est des essuie glace.
Il y a peut être une voiture en dessous,
la ceinture de sécurité et les essuie glace.
Ici, il y a que des morceaux de voiture
dans ce canal.
On le sait
Attends je relance
Parce que...
pour l'instant, c'est
ce que j'appelle un test très concluant.
On va en faire un avec deux aimants
Barbarian.
Troisième remontée et troisième objet
je pense donc
très très validé pour l'instant.
Je vais continuer à pêcher avec ça
pendant toute la vidéo.
Après, je le prêterais à Quentin
Regarde regarde
C'est remplis
Oui, il y a plein de choses
Je sais pas si c'est les aimants qui sont
neufs et qui sont super puissants, mais
il est double ce panneau
Oui, d'habitude, on a que des simples
Sympa, puis.
Pour l'instant, pas d'accident,
ils ne s'accrochent pas entre eux
Allez
double Beast contre barbarian
on va voir ce que ça donne.
Ah oui.
D'accord, j'ai quelque chose.
OK, c'est un morceau de
De solex ou quoi ? De scooter
On a trouvé le même il y a pas longtemps
C'est des morceaux de mobylette, ça,
je crois.
Toujours penser à vérifier
si c'est encore bien serré.
Parce que c'est vrai que
on est pas comme sur les aimants classiques,
il n'y a pas d'écrous ici.
Donc, il y a seulement le pas de vis,
toujours vérifier votre attache.
ici pour le test
on ne voulait pas fixer
définitivement nos aimants,
sinon vous pouvez mettre
de la colle exprès dans le pas de vis
disponible aussi
sur le site de maison de la détection
Ça y est
Ok de l'os ?
non plastique.
J'ai crus que c'était
un bout de mâchoire avec les moules.
Mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est
que qui dit doublement
dit aussi deux fois plus de poids.
Donc pour les coins
ou il y a beaucoup de vase,
ça racle le fond
d'accord
Et voilà, ça
permet aussi d'attraper des moules,
des boulons qui viennent du pont.
Et je pense que mettre double aimants barbarians
ce serait de la gourmandise
Oh ! Du morceau de voiture encore.
Il y a un feu
ou un feu aquarium.
OK, j'aime bien
Je crois avoir un petit truc
ce couteau ne rigole pas du tout
Il est magnifique, ouah !
Un peu cassé là
Pense au mec qui jette ça dans le canal...
il est super bizarre même.
Pourquoi ça dépasse là ?
Le bois est cassé
Mais c'est pas un truc de boucher ça c'est
un poignard avec le bord comme ça.
Franchement dîtes nous en commentaires si vous connaissez
un peu les couteaux, mais il est effrayant
celui là.
Ouais
Bien joué, merci.
Rasta calme toi
Salut ça va ?
T'as quelque chose là ?
Un poids correct
Ah oui d'accord
On a quelque chose de pas magnétique,
C'est une brique ou un bout de béton
Même pas magnétique
Mais c'est ça.
Ben ça fait un effet grappin en fait.
ça va mon petit rasta ?
Tu te promènes dans le fenouil ?
Un petit coffre fort.
Là, ce serait pas mal
Oui ce serait très bien
Déjà, t'as fait un joli couteau,
ça commence bien.
On est là depuis pas longtemps.
Il y a quelque chose
Une boîte de conserve ?
Bah ouais, du coup, c'est intéressant.
Belle trouvaille. Un petite enceinte
Ouais je pense qu'elle est morte,
mais les boutons fonctionnent
Comme quoi il reste des choses dans la vase
Sympa.
Et pour ceux qui se demandent si jamais
on trouve vraiment quelque chose qui fait
2800 kilos, on a toujours un treuil de
six tonnes à portée de main
et au pire,
on arrivera toujours
à décrocher l'aimant en plongeant.
Est ce qu'on a quelque chose ?
Eh oui,
les doubles ont tenu leurs promesses.
On a une espèce de durite
et des morceaux de grillage.
Alors oui,
certains me diront que c'est pas fou,
mais c'est déjà un bon début.
Et c'est par des petites choses
qu'on finit par trouver un vrai trésor.
On a fait un short sur Xavier
Dupont de Ligonnès
et je me suis fait gronder
parce que j'avais dit
Il "avait apparu" plein de gens
qui m'ont dit Ouais, ça se dit pas,
c'est était apparu nanana
Du coup, j'ai vérifié et bien "avait apparu",
ça se dit très bien.
Et donc voilà, je sais parler
le français,
moi aussi un peu
On va de l'autre côté ?
Ouais
Il y a rien
On vient
de passer de l'autre côté du pont.
On va regarder ce que ça donne ici.
Il y a une petite route abandonnée là,
C'est toujours possible de trouver des choses,
Mais ça n'a pas l'air très magnétique.
J'espère que c'est pas du bois.
oula regarde
Pas magnétique
C'est ça en moins dans l'eau
Je n'étais pas près de louper ça
avec les deux aimants.
Un morceau de voiture. Ouais, je pense.
Je pense que moi aussi parierai sur ça là.
Mon objet n'accroche pas bien et retombe à chaque fois
Toi tu devrais y arriver
Tu devrais le sentir là
Oui, j'avais raison.
Et oui, tu vois, un aimant de chaque côté
Comme ça, c'est parfait.
Avec un seul aimant il faudrait vraiment qu'il se coince dans un angle
Oh purée
On a été un peu optimistes
Ça y est, je l'ai de nouveau.
J'ai l'impression
qu'il est encore plus lourd que tout à l'heure.
OK, c'est bien le même.
C'est pas un morceau de voiture, non ?
Et l'autre tout non plus
d'ailleurs, c'est pareil.
C'est le même.
ça vient d'un toit ?
Je pense
C'est pas
sais pas si vous savez en commentaire.
aide moi
Mais c'est lourd,
c'est pas de la tôle de merde
et elle est pas vieille.
Oh, il y a les découpes, c'est
encore brillant là.
Il y a de la vase dedans quand même.
C'est pour ça aussi que c'est lourd. Ouais ouais,
Allez on continue.
Pour les morceaux de carrosserie.
Je pense que c'est le top.
T'as encore quelque chose ? Parce que d'habitude
ils viennent jamais du premier coup
Ouais c'est galère.
ça vient bien
Ouais, enfin
C'est un toit non ? c'est
facile à mettre dans l'utilitaire ça.
Ils ont bien travaillé.
merci Maison de la détection pour les aimants qui marchent bien.
Si vous voulez le vôtre, on l'a déjà dit,
mais tout est en description.
On conseille en général le terror
pour débuter comme ça avec deux terrors
Ça doit être le top aussi
même si là on l'a fait avec deux Beast
Mais ça se fait avec tous types d'aimants
pendant que Quentin ne trouve rien
avec son simple aimant
Nous on a plein de trucs avec le double
Mets toi dans la même ligne.
C'est pas si lourd
la forme est bizarre
La carrosserie.
Mais ça une forme bizarre.
C'est plat encore
Nettoie le bien.
Moi, c'est terrible de trouver
autant de morceaux de voitures dans le canal
il faut les sortir.
C'est sûr on préfère trouver du coffre fort et des armes à feu.
Mais ça fait toujours plaisir et ce sera emmené chez
le ferrailleur,
on va le plier en deux lui
C'est recyclé
au moins
Il est retombé
j'en ai perdu un
Du blanc encore.
C'est la même voiture
Non, non.
Alors si vous cherchez
votre voiture volée,
peut être qu'elle est tout simplement là
Dîtes nous si vous reconnaissez votre voiture
OK d'accord
Il y en a d'autres morceaux.
Il est tout neuf,
c'est pas vieux, c'est
un morceau d'utilitaire ça.
Le Peugeot expert est encore là bas ?
Ouais, c'est bon,
il est neuf celui là.
C'est rare qu'on en trouve des si récents
Au moins il n'y a même pas de vase dedans
le ferrailleur va se poser des questions
C'est vous qui les découpez ? Dîtes la vérité
Il y a même pas de vase à l'intérieur.
Ils l'ont jeté dans la nuit, lui.
Il y en a plein là
j'avais le pied dessus.
En plus, avec les quatre kilos du truc,
là, ça m'a presque jeté dans l'eau.
Ça pardonne moins.
Regarde lui là
Regarde le,
tu le vois
C'est bizarre, il vient pas du tout,
il est neuf aussi
Incroyable que la personne qui a fait ça
en commentaire se dénonce.
Ça doit être plein. Tout le long
À quel moment les mecs se disent
on va se garer là et on va jeter
Un utilitaire découpé.
On peut les voir du pont, c'est dingue.
Bon, d'accord,
il doivent faire ça à 5 h du matin
Mais même
ça me parait fou,
il y a tellement de meilleurs endroits
pour jeter
Qu'est ce qu'il y a ?
On a oublié les croquettes ?
Sans mentir, j'ai
deux fois plus de chance de les avoir
avec le setup comme ça.
Et regarde
pourtant j'en ai eu qu'un dessus. C'est une portière
Ouais, faut que tu m'aides
OK. J'adore les portières,
c'est toujours original à repêcher
Dîtes nous en commentaires
les connaisseurs portières arrière.
La poignet est assez moderne
ça commence à faire du poids
j'en ai enfin un
Ne te réjouis pas trop vite
C'est autre chose
C'est
une portière avec un jouet pour enfant.
Elle est plus ancienne
Ça, c'est bien joué.
peut être une portière
encore. J'en peux plus
entre le doublement de quatre
kilos à lancer et les morceaux de voiture.
Je suis cuit déjà, ouais ça fatigue
Elle est remplie.
De vase,
OK
C'est une boite
avec quelque chose à l'intérieur.
Regarde, il y a un truc dedans.
Je pense.
Ça c'est dans les voitures.
Un peu déçu. Un caddie ?
Les caddies ?
Les petits caddies ?
Non, non, non, il est mlinuscule
dont la journée commence à décliner.
Mais on a encore des beaux objets, donc.
Le gros, c'est le plus gros de la journée.
Il y a moyen oui
On commence à le voir regarde
Vas y doucement pour ne pas le perdre
fais un lasso vas y
montre des talents de cowboy
Oui quand j'étais jeune
1,2,3
C'est mieux
C'est bien.
Mais c'est ça, au moins dans l'eau.
Bah ça reste une belle pêche à l'aimant
belle pêche, beau voyage chez le ferrailleur,
on a quand même fait un joli couteau.
Mais c'est vrai que pas trop d'objets
originaux.
Après, voilà, c'est pas tous les jours
qu'on remonte des voitures.
De l'eau non plus.
Ouais.
Ça me fait du bien un peu. Ça entretient
à Marly-Gomont y a pas de béton
C'est limite
Et voilà
il manque un peu, on pousse
1,2,3
C'est bon